before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
well let's see if we can find any
treasure in this one
[Music]
the legend of the sea devils
we are coming to the end of jodie
whittaker's time as the doctor and this
time we get the return of a classic era
doctor who creature which i fairly
recently uh re-watched the original
appearance of you can check that review
out there if you haven't seen it already
over in the break room of geeks
but i
like the sea devils i've always kind of
liked the sea devils and i was excited
to see them back i was excited for
pirates
i like pirates
i like curse the black spot more than it
deserves simply because it has pirates
so
this thing it was kind of teeing up for
me to
probably like it
and
it's okay
i mean that that's kind of it what's
here's what's interesting about this one
it's not great
however
this is a case where most of the
problems with it i can actually chalk up
to the fact that it isn't longer i've
seen some people say that like this
should have been like a two or even
three part story i'm not sure it needed
that it didn't need at least 15 more
minutes
minimum
because
the i'm seeing all this stuff there
and all the things stuff that's in place
i'm like
it's not that it's not working it's that
it needs a little bit more time than it
gets
and there's a lot of stuff i feel that
with and none of it's stuff that i would
cut
so in a more poorly constructed thing i
might think okay look there was enough
time but you should have cut this entire
subplot thing then you would have had
the time to get everything else to do
like i'm not sure there's anything i'd
actually cut from this
but it does need more time than it gets
i feel like the characters the guest
characters are a really good example of
that
so like whether we're talking uh madam
ching or jihoon or
i forget the other character's name but
the one whose father dies in the opening
uh yin
kai yin ki
something like that um with those three
by the end i actually was like you know
what the actors are putting a fair
amount of characterization into them of
all three
and like they have moments again
especially towards the end where's like
this feels like a culmination
of moments that we didn't get
so it doesn't feel like the performances
are bad it feels like the performances
are good but we're missing a little bit
more time a little bit more connective
tissue a little bit more chances for
characterization than they actually got
to have i think similarly with the lead
um sea devil as well
actually decently characterized i kind
of like right off the bat the doctor
says sea devil and he's like
land parasite or something like that
because like sea devils not what they
should actually be called that was just
what some dude at like a lighthouse or a
radar station or whatever the heck it
was in the original story he called them
that's just what they've been known as
ever since that's not what they actually
are so as far as he's concerned that's
an insult so i like he just spat an
insult right back at the doctor and it
was kind of funny that she got offended
by it like
do you did you not realize that when you
called him see
but
um i also i like the design it reminds
me in a lot of ways of the redesign on
the ice warriors incredibly reminiscent
immediately identifiable as what it was
in the classic era but judged up just
enough
to not feel completely dated um i
actually this is one of the few cases
where i feel like it works where they
have the like the glowing thing on them
that lights up as he talks because
they've they've also got like movement
they've got like a bladder in the neck
so it's like
so it's moving but it doesn't have to
lip sync mouth movements which is
ultimately one of the hardest things to
do in animatronics is to try and match
lip movements to normal uh natural
sounding speech they get around that by
having like so there's movement here but
the sound is like is linking this that's
a good compromise they bring back sort
of the whispery nature of the
uh sea devil's voice without it sounding
as annoying and slow as it did in the
original they move pretty decently
there's um nice movement in the eyes
like even subtle movements of time like
narrowing the eyes and stuff i thought
they looked good
i don't think they ever confirmed that
the sea monster was the murka
i wish they would have
i'm gonna assume it is
um it is a here's the main reason it
annoys me that i didn't catch them
confirming that that was the murka
um
if you don't know classic doctor who the
murka appeared in um in a classic doctor
who episode called uh warriors of the
deep which is real bad
real real bad reviewed it there with a
stew bag full holy cow that thing's so
so bad um and the merc is one of the
most infamous things about it but like i
i really like the idea of going back to
something that flat out didn't work and
giving it another go
part of the reason i kind of wish they
had identified it as the merka is
because
there really isn't a reason for it to be
there
so you might as well give us the proper
fan service of acknowledging what it is
and before you jump and say well could
that be the subplot that was cut like
things got 45 seconds total screen time
altogether
um and another thing that feels like
it's reminiscent of like this
this as originally scripted
may have even intended to have had more
time there's a couple of points where
things just jump forward in
weird ways so like
suddenly madame ching's back on her boat
when
like last we saw it she was on land with
the companions and with uh ying
but now suddenly she's back on her ship
and the kid wants to go follow her
and
dan is like with him and it was like
okay i guess we'll do that and the
doctor is with yaz and the tardis and be
like well we'll just leave dan and go do
something like
it's like it's like we completely
dropped a scene to get madam ching back
to her ship so like the stuff that's
wrong with it is that kind of stuff
it's nuts and bolts stuff that doesn't
make it not issues and there's a lot of
little weird moments like that so
there's stuff like that which is weird
and there's dan suddenly like wiping out
a whole bunch of sea devils just by
with the sword i'm like not one of those
sea devils raised their own weapons to
block it not a one
not a one they just all conveniently
stood in a way that he could take out
all of them into slashes
really
you know there's stuff like that and
none of that's good
but that's nuts and bolts stuff that's
stuff that is affected by
possibly the difficulties of filming
with kovid restrictions possibly um you
know having to shave time out of it if
the thing just ended up being longer
than they thought it was going to be and
them having to nickel die and dime time
out of it and again none of that is to
defend it none of these are good things
that i'm pointing out but the reason i'm
pointing them out is because
chipnel at his worst
engages in ideas that i don't think are
worth engaging in in the first frickin
place that's kind of how i feel about
the timeless child that's not a problem
specific to chibno for the record i
still hold moffat and friggin hellbent
as like the worst example of why would
you even
do this regardless of whether or not i
succeeded why would you even do that at
all
but that's not what's going on here now
that doesn't make this the best that
chibnall can do chimneal can do better
than this this kind of falls in the
middle with chibnall which is that the
idea is perfectly sound
and
there are bits and pieces and aspects
and elements that are even good like i
said the performances from the guest
cast kind of point to that they're well
characterized as far as the performers
have a lot of confidence in the
characters they're playing
but they're not well characterized in
terms of the amount of screen time in
the amount the audience actually gets to
know them
so
this isn't a case of the idea
was never gonna work this is a case of
this has the elements that could have
worked with just a little more care
and probably more time
so
that's sort of where i'm i'm frustrated
by this one i suppose i need to bring up
the doctor
and yes
huh
i don't know what else i was expecting
at this point in hindsight
i think it might have been
oh well i was going to say foolish to
expect but i think it it
it's surprising now in hindsight for me
to think that people were expecting a
much different response other than the
doctor basically saying i would like to
but i can't
because here's the thing
my thoughts on the ship aside again
video that i've kind of done talking
about it like i don't like the idea of a
doctor in a romantic pairing especially
with a companion i just don't
um like as much as i love the chemistry
between the doctor and
various doctors and river like
just the general idea of the doctor
romantically involved just is it's not
generally my thing i don't really care
for it i really don't like it with a
regular companion
the thing is i'm not the only one who
feels that way and that's not me being
like you should listen to me but i mean
like the idea of the doctor even kissing
a campaign was a taboo like the entire
run of classic doctor who
like
people need to remember when paul
mcgann's eighth doctor
kissed the woman that was effectively
his companion in the tv movie in 1996
that was a huge deal and it ticked fans
off
now modern era doctor who has kind of
skirted the line on this because we've
had
the doctor share kisses with a lot more
companions than i would like to have
ever had happen sometimes implied
romantically sometimes for
weirdly contrived reasons
sometimes for comedic effect but
you know
the show has kind of always skirted
right up to the line like the closest
that it came was something like
uh the 10th doctor in rose
where while i will always appreciate at
the very end of doomsday
that we don't hear the doctor finish the
sentence
that he was saying to rose it's hard to
imagine he was going to say anything
other than i love you
but again given
how much of the fandom isn't here for
shipping
and again i'm not saying that that makes
it a a priority fan but i'm saying
there's a needle to thread here
and something like that moment at the
end of doomsday gives it a case where
like
what the heck else was he gonna say
which is to some degree throwing a bone
to the shippers but we also don't
actually have to hear him say it we're
just throwing a bone to people like me
so
this is kind of trying to do a similar
threading of the needle
acknowledging
the attraction and the interest
but not actually moving forward with it
which
i mean for my personal opinion as
someone who's not really here to ever
see the doctor in a romantic
relationship is about the best that i
personally could have hoped for i
understand if other people are going to
be disappointed and feel like it's a cop
out
i would say it's actually super
consistent
with
the way they've handled the doctor and
romantic inclinations in the modern era
you know this
leaning into it not denying it but also
not actually pursuing it as a storyline
that's
that's really kind of the way that
modern era doctor who has largely
handled it and you know i still prefer
the instances where that's not on the
table between the doctor and the
companions but
now that tracks
it does
it is one of the other things that like
needed a little bit more space not
necessarily that it needed more raw time
but i think if it had more well you know
where it needed more space is we needed
to introduce this entire idea of the as
in the doctor being a thing earlier than
the episode prior to this because
like that moment between the doctor and
yaz when the doctor was like
i'm not a bad date am i and there's like
this weird awkward pause between them
that's real contrived
that line but it's something that could
have worked if it had been built up to
longer than just the immediate prior
episode like honestly the idea of yaz
crushing on the doctor at the very least
if not the doctor reciprocating
something that really should have been
introduced during flux
somewhere
at some point
uh
and and then look i i i know like
the people really into the ship will say
well it was hinted at long before that
but again i just kind of did a video on
that like there was nothing definitive
for a very long time it was vague
hinting that you could not be sure you
weren't just reading into it
so to actually commit to doing it as a
storyline to my mind should have
happened
at the latest part way into flux so that
we could watch this
understanding of their of their
attraction how they're drawn to each
other grow between the characters in
something more organ more organic than
yeah
i'm not a bad dad am i
which like it's not performed bad and
the the like i keep i keep feeling this
about chibno
like the outline of the scene
would read fine the actual dialogue that
they have it's
not
great
but
that just kind of
is what it is
and
i did have fun with this i enjoyed the
sea devils i enjoyed the sword fight i
liked the flying ship as briefly as we
saw the dang thing
you know there's
this has
the vibe in the fun
atmosphere
that i like out of pirate stories
so while i've got a hesitant to say that
like
i i
well i definitely don't love this i was
hesitant to say that i even really
like it
i will say
i probably like it more than i would
under any other circumstances just for
the pirate vibe
i'm a sucker i'm a sucker for pirates
like that's that's just a fact of me and
that gives you a little more leeway than
sometimes some things probably deserve
i
certainly don't regret watching this and
i don't think i'll mind watching it
again i'm not sure i'm gonna jump on it
like i i actually did watch uh eva the
daleks again after that air because
i actually still maintained that the way
the time loop was done was pretty decent
and while there were some stumbles in
that and i mentioned in them in my
review like i think that's one of
chimney's better pieces it's one of his
tighter ones it's decently done
i liked that i'm not going to jump to
watching this one again
but i also
won't really have a problem watching it
again i won't dread watching it again
it'll just be like oh yeah
this one this was just fun
and it's not amazing fun
because you know there are some doctor
who episodes that are just fun like
robots sure would that's just fun
but that's a level of fun that's
significantly higher than this but the
degree to which i enjoy this is on this
similar
yeah that's fun
kind of level
like nuts and bolts issues
uh needed more time but
despite itself i still had fun for the
most part of course i should probably
talk in some way about the next time on
doctor who thing i don't remember
the
shots
uh from the end of series 12 well enough
to know for certain whether
uh whether the images of assad
were new or recycled
i'm hoping that they're new because
assad was a great villain and a great
concept that was ultimately squandered
so i would love to have him back we know
we're getting the master back which also
in theory is going to tie together the
um the whole timeless child stuff
and wrap that up completely
which i suppose is the other reason that
like
the the doctrine yes they had to go the
way that it did they don't have the time
to actually explore the two of them in a
relationship so honestly since they
started it as late as they did it's
probably narratively just narratively
storytelling why is it better to just
not
because it's gonna be so brief it's like
what was the point of even exploring it
so
it's
like if they were gonna like truly
properly explore it needed to start a
heck of a lot sooner but anyways uh then
of course there's the other thing tegan
ace
uh taking with a gun feels off to me
especially given why tegan
left the tardis in the first place
hoping we'll get an explanation for that
ace with a gun oh yeah i buy that i buy
that in a heartbeat that like yeah
totally
so
uh you know a bunch of other people we
saw we saw kate
uh again in there
i haven't mentioned dan from this
episode he was
he was
sweet and affable he's dan he does what
dan does
and uh as far as the next time i know
some people are like really super like
losing their minds over oh hey cintiq
and i'm like
good
that'll hopefully be nice to see them
back but
this thing's gonna have a lot to do you
know in terms of
being a regeneration story theoretically
tying off the timeless child story
dealing with the sasha dewan master and
what might be his last appearance who
knows
bringing in old characters well
new old characters like kate and old
characters like tegan or ace
it's a lot and
i don't trust gymnal to handle
a lot i feel like when he's done his
best
it's with stories that were
a lot simpler and i think that's why i
will always look at something like eve
of the dogs and go like that works so
much better than flux
because the more he does the less he
knows how to balance it
but
i will
as always
hope for the best
but for right now
legend of the sea devils
what'd you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it like share subscribe patreon
that's how i pay the bills and i am able
to do this as my
living any amount you're able to
contribute is of great help but don't
worry about it too much
what i really want you to remember is
that
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
and credits i gotta shout out my top
patreon supporters so thank you very
much to zubin luthfullah barack oliver
bean melinda walters lyotha boy tt for
nobulax the poodle idol tracy scrabbat
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
adam lefty taylor shane ross robin moore
shayla gourley and brendan the rose
couldn't do it without you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]